a lot of people these days think the big
news stories are either the upcoming
presidential election or the upcoming
London Olympics well judging by local
news apparently there's an even bigger
story that's sweeping the nation right
now here's a look at today's real top
story and welcome back to the show I
scream you scream you know the rest I
scream you scream you know the rest
syan scream you scream you know the rest
I scream you scream lol I scream you
scream you know the rest I scream you
scream well you know the rough I scream
you scream well you know the rest I
scream you scream we all well you know
the rest I scream you scream you know
the breath I scream you scream we all
know the rest I scream you scream you
know the rest I scream you scream well
you know the rest I scream you scream
you know the rest I scream you scream
yah know the rest of it oh right I
scream you scream well you know the rest
I scream you scream you know the rest I
scream you scream and you know the rest
I scream you scream you know the rest I
scream you scream well you know the rest
well I scream you scream clips I think
you know the rest I see you scream you
know the rest everybody knows the rest I
scream you scream well you know the rest
I scream you scream you know the rest I
scream you scream and you know the rest
I scream you scream you know the rest
[Applause]
I don't find that funny I find it scary
it scares me